(bright violin music)
- [Narrator] Once a hub of
French aristocratic parties,
this castle in the
countryside lies abandoned
after falling victim to a house fire.
A few hours outside Paris are the remains
of the chateau de La Mothe-Chandeniers.
The castle was built in the 14th century
and was owned by French nobles.
It was conquered twice by the
British in the Middle Ages
and was devastated during
the French Revolution.
Around 60 years later,
after a wealthy relative
of Napoleon III took control,
he restored the castle
to its former glory.
However, in 1932, just after
central heating was installed,
a violent fire broke out.
Since the fire, the castle
has been slowly taken over
by nature.
Trees have grown through the interior,
and vines crawl along the
once sturdy castle walls.
Though its fate is still uncertain,
today there are efforts to save the castle
with a group raising money
to restore the ruins.